[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc ça c'est quand ils sont contents en
fait c'est ça non mais j'essaie
après c'est un groupe voilà faut pas non
plus
sur les champs ça me faisait plaisir de
les voir ils ont chanter pour danser
c'était comme des fous après donc comme
partout tu as toujours des abrutis je
suis désolé
faut pas non plus à chaque fois dire
c'est toujours voilà il faut pas
généraliser c'est pas quand tu as 10
abrutis en plus de bruit que c'est 1000
personnes qui sont sortis
tu pourras jamais empêcher ça
exactement
11 arrestations une garde à vue donc
résumer le match Maroc Belgique
je vous rappelle qu'à des scènes de
pillage avec des gens masqués et vous
voulez et j'ai lu aujourd'hui le
communiqué de la police belge qui dit
nous avons été victime de débordement
des deux bords voilà donc une cible pas
les Marocains il y a aussi des Belges de
nationalité belge né en Belgique tout ce
que vous voulez et profitez donc les
Marocains s'il vous plaît il y a une
image qui a fait beaucoup parler
regardez c'est cette image quand
justement le drapeau est retiré
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire Raymond
un ça me blesse bah ouais ça me blesse
parce que tu peux chercher toutes les
excuses du monde tu peux dire c'est pas
eux c'est 10 c'est 12 c'est 13 on voit
des mecs avec un drapeau marocain qui
casse un feu rouge je vois pas l'intérêt
on voit un marocain avec un drapeau
marocain qui monte enlever un drapeau
belge avec des Marocains en bas
puisqu'ils ont le drapeau marocain qui
applaudissent soit pas l'intérêt et une
fois de plus va t'amuser au Maroc de
décrocher un maillot à un drapeau
marocain au Maroc tu vas voir ce qui va
t'arriver on va te prendre par les pieds
on va te faire tourner c'est ça qui me
dérange non non ce qui me dérange c'est
que c'est ces gens-là on a c'est les
mêmes en France les petits footers de
merde comme ça qui se disent on est
marocain et qui foutent le bordel et qui
casse le pays quand ils sont au Maroc
moi je reviens du Maroc je reviens il y
a 15 jours les vélos ils sont pas
attachés dans la rue j'ai vu des vélos
devant des écoles pas attaché j'y mets
pourquoi vous les vélos sont pas
attachés on va pas les volets nous aussi
les vélos on les voit jamais les vélos
ici parce que il y a là-bas il y a ce
qu'on appelle une justice qui rigole pas
il y a la loi qui rigole pas là on a
l'impression que la loi on s'en fout
qu'on peut monter comme ça sur un balcon
décrocher un drapeau belge moi ça me
fait énormément de énormément de mal et
tu sais très bien pourquoi ça me fait du
mal parce que je suis d'origine
marocaine mais quand je vois ça j'ai
honte des gens qui ont le drapeau
marocain sur leur dos qui casse comme ça
j'ai honte alors peut-être que tu peux
me répondre
c'est la mieux passée elle est moitié
belge moitié marocaine c'est pas ça les
Marocains donc en fait moi je suis de
naissance belge et donc d'origine
marocaine comme je l'ai déjà dit dans
l'émission et c'est sûr que bah ça fait
mal au cœur en fait oui moi ça me choque
ça me je trouve ça vraiment en fait ça
me fatigue je trouve ça dommage mais je
tiens à dire que la communauté
maghrébine et marocaine sont je veux
dire des gens qui travaillent dans la
société civile c'est pas que des
casseurs
d'amalgame par rapport à ça et bien sûr
que moi je dénonce ça je trouve ça moche
je trouve ça franchement qu'ils aillent
faire du sport pour se défouler quoi je
veux dire je trouve ça dommage de mettre
toute cette énergie négative après voilà
moi je peux pas je peux pas défendre
dans leur tête des
manifestations la meilleure
visualisation ont un cancer c'est les
Black Blocs les casseurs et tout c'est
impossible de les dissocier dès qu'il y
a un mouvement de foule il y a des mecs
qui sont là pour
être un moment de fraternité quand même
le foot généralement je le dis il
rassemble beaucoup donc c'est vrai que
voilà c'est voilà et après il y a
toujours des folies c'est pas vrai c'est
pareil c'est pas vrai
Angleterre quand ils viennent les
hooligans à Marseille
c'était qui au stade de France attention